gerrae brewster the cabinet member for
economy on mid Suffolk District Council
for the second time I was elected in
back in 2011 a typical day obviously we
we do have meetings planning meetings or
whatever but my work as a member for
economy is to work with business to
support business through problems that I
would have in terms of accessing council
services and we do have residents
talking to us about whatever concerns
them personally I'm always open to
anyone who wishes to speak to me I think
if anyone really wanted to get involved
in local politics
I think certainly they could they could
approach any member of the Council to to
have a chat and just really find out
what it's about you know we have an
election coming up in 2019 in May of
that year if people feel that they would
like to make a difference in their
community then they have the opportunity
to do so at that stage why should they
go ahead and stand they couldn't make a
difference to their community but from
their own personal perspective
achievement on council for the benefit
of the wider population they get a kick
out of it you know we do get enjoyment
out of what we do I really become a
caster to try and make a difference to
the community and to the wider area of
mid Suffolk